ken is how are you doing I'm fine I'm
waiting for the chicken and I'm going to
plate it and that's it so there honey
and the mustard room there guys and it
mean to be culinary genius today in mean
a lot because it is Gordon who inspired
me to cook and if I could do something
to amaze him I'll be really happy and
what would you do with the money huh
money so I really planned to give half
of it to UNICEF to give it to the
children because they also have me to
opportunity to learn right they're not
lucky as me that I too have this
opportunity
like you learn everything so no
experience carry on carry on right just
on today's video are you happy and
well-enough you will fly a starship
Anthony because it started around your
season then see fit here we go
where is the chicken it's in the whole
thing what do you think I'm fine if it's
much enough but it's okay what's in
there that place I'm chicken
close the glazed one the things that you
conjure you'll still get that bread
tastes like a pie um I'm a bit panicking
close the doors and we will cook the
door open um okay what's going on here
I'm just a garnish time distant commerce
and just a vegetable vegetables I've got
thick beans on there I got like what
we've done with the onions to summarize
it just pan fight it and then viciously
vicious tiger to idiot of go time 90
seconds to get that bird on a plate good
luck
thirty Seconds
it's not cooking enough Kenneth start
plating please yes um it was not on the
plate we can't judge it 15 seconds to go
10 9 8
Oh Kenneth yeah describe so there's a
honey and must likely stick to your best
yeah but the oven is I didn't put it
enough time so this part is a bit low so
if you want to try this on so that this
comes with a health warning
I do not perfect this okay you baited
the chicken and garlic yeah caramelize
the onions yeah it was kinda like onions
with Sal Champa asked you back um so
honey glazed so those you sugar
this gets to be crispy if the chicken is
pink I can't eat it yeah absolutely the
end of the chicken is tasty overall you
know it needs a little bit more umph
you're packed with energy I just want
some of that energy on the plate onions
delicious crispy skin
unfortunately pink chicken is not good
for you at this time of the afternoon
yes overall what would you say to you
know if you want a breast to take the
path I just took the five